what I'm focused on is delivering for
the British public now I recognize we
have made mistakes I'm sorry for those
mistakes but I fixed the mistakes I've
appointed a new Chancellor we have
restored economic stability and fiscal
discipline and what I now want to do is
go on and deliver for the public we were
elected on the 2019 Manifesto I'm
determined to deliver on that leveling
up securing investment into all parts of
our country getting roads built getting
opportunities right across the nation
and that's what I'm thinking about
that's what I'm focused on your
colleague Charles Walker has said you've
got a maximum of two weeks before you're
removed from office what would be your
message to him and others on your own
Ventures who are saying things like that
my message is we should be focusing on
delivering for the British public we are
in difficult Economic Times we're in
difficult International times with the
war being perpetrated in Ukraine and now
is the time to focus on delivering
making sure that we are delivering on
our energy package so before we stepped
in people were facing energy bills of up
to six thousand pounds we've now put in
place the energy price guarantee we've
reverse the National Insurance increase
and that's what I'm thinking about as
prime minister